America's most powerful tech companies
already know more about you than your
parents do they share that information
with others they make billions doing it
just today Facebook admitted it gave
data on 87 million people to Cambridge
analytic at no big deal tech companies
drive economic inequality they've done
that a lot in California they collude
with one another to suppress free speech
while their CEOs demand an end to gun
rights from behind a wall of armed
guards they create addictive services
and deliberately get children hooked on
them then they'll brag about how I'll be
able to buy themselves immortality in
the end they're even creating new risks
for national defense
so what defense can be made of the tech
industry which increasingly occupies a
central place in our lives Dean Garfield
who's president of the information
technology industry Council and he joins
us 19 thanks for coming out thanks a lot
of way I see you're a big fan of ours
well you know I there are things I mean
these companies are successful because
they're amazing Google is an amazing
product Facebook is an amazing product I
would never deny that and they're
American companies so I'm proud of that
right but there's a massive downside
that has been suppressed and I could
name a lot here's just one the more you
use Facebook according to study after
study after study the less happy you
become we've seen a massive spike in
suicide rates especially among kids I'm
not saying they're driven by Facebook I
am saying we should take a close look at
things that are affecting kids emotional
well-being
these are credible studies you're
familiar with them how is this different
an addictive product that hurts people
from cigarettes well I think it's quite
different from cigarettes in that there
is demonstrated evidence that smoking
nicotine is addictive and is bad for
your health I don't think that evidence
exists for Facebook or other social
media but that being said most of them
most of the companies that we represent
understand their responsibility to
society and are making sure that they're
evaluating what's going on and taking
steps to make sure that it's not doing
harm there's no evidence okay so here's
Sean Parker he's the founding president
of Facebook here's what he said November
9th and he described his company its
exploiting a vulnerability in human
psychology it literally changes your
relationship with society with others it
probably interferes with productivity
God knows what
to our children's brains but we do know
because the Journal of Epidemiology
found that the quote the more people the
more people use Facebook the less
healthy they are and the less satisfied
with their lives especially true of
children study after study after study
we know it hurts people unless we think
science is invalid and we know that it
was designed to be addictive so how is
that allowed I don't think we know that
it's designed to be addictive and as
well the people who run and founded
those companies didn't create them with
addiction or doing harm in mind they
created them to do something pretty
phenomenal as you noted which is to
deepen social connections how's that but
that hasn't happened I mean there's no
study people I'll tell you how because
there's not a single and we've looked at
it pretty closely there's not a single
study that has shown that the more you
use social media the more connected you
are to people you may communicate with
them more but in no true sense are you
more connected in fact Ramar isolated
and that's what these studies and I have
all of them 2015 University of Missouri
2013 huge one 2016 all of these show
that social media use decreases life
satisfaction because it alienates people
from each other why won't the companies
admit that my sense is that in my view
is that there is little reason to admit
something that's still quite nascent and
still being studied I think there's a
lot of conversation about the
neurological implications and a deep
desire to get to the bottom of what the
implications are and if if there is a
problem than to do something about it
how much money is Google for example or
Facebook spending on researching this I
don't think any of these studies were
funded by the industry no I don't think
so either
right so it doesn't sound like they're
taking the responsibility so let's give
a macro question which is this I
wouldn't say that at all in fact I
adamantly disagree I think the companies
do take this seriously that's why how
much are they spending studying it I
don't know that's not to suggest that
they're not studying it right in fact in
all the discussions today about
legislation around these issues like the
honest act most of the response from the
companies have been not adamantly
opposed but let's have a conversation
about what the implications are but
billions and billions and billions and
billions of profit dollars into this has
been going on for more
ten years there's been evidence for a
while that it might be harmful why
haven't they taken the lead in this
because they don't care right wrong look
anytime you want to come back we've hit
the tech companies really hard and if
there's countervailing evidence I really
want to see it so if they're they have
initiatives to address these things I
hope you'll come on you'll always have
space here to talk about them absolutely
well great thank you very much